france info patrick picard fait
aujourd'hui systématiquement le plein de
sa voiture à l'éthanol pour des raisons
écologiques bien sûr mais aussi et
surtout parce que c'est beaucoup moins
cher
il n'a pas vraiment le choix de
surveiller ses dépenses salarié chez
michelin depuis 1979 il y ait de quitter
l'entreprise dans le cadre d'un plan de
réduction des effectifs
un cas loin d'être isolé le géant du
pneumatique a beaucoup délocalisé au
cours des dernières années et prévoit
couper encore mille postes 10 yens moi
quand je vais rentrer à clermont ferrand
on était trente deux mille à clermont
ferrand
maintenant l'om dix mille et il reste
plus qu'un ou deux ateliers où on
fabrique encore détenues après 40 ans de
service patrick gagnait 2000 euros par
mois soit environ 36 mille dollars par
année
je prends me plaindre avec 2000 euros ou
rien mais bon au bout de quarante ans on
peut espérer peut-être un peu mieux
aujourd'hui en pré retraite sont revenus
a fondu de 25 %
alors comme de plus en plus de français
il se préoccupe de son pouvoir d'achat
des paniers d'épicerie vide pour
symboliser la difficulté de joindre les
deux bouts
un thème récurrent et manifestations de
gilet jaune à clermont ferrand
je les soutiens dans les idées je les
soutiens les jaunes
je vais prier dans une manifestation
mais plutôt que d'enfiler un gilet jaune
de défier les autorités
patrick a plutôt choisi d'être
pragmatiques et constructif
le président à julie dans la lettre
adressée aux français avait visé quatre
grands thèmes en participant par exemple
à cette assemblée citoyenne organisée
dans le cadre du grand débat national
initié par emmanuel macron le thème sans
surprise le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir
d'achat j'en ai perdu parce que je reste
chez moi mais je j'ai perdu 25 % du
salaire
effectivement notre pouvoir d'achat nos
fonctionnaires qui faisions partie de la
classe moyenne il y a quinze ans encore
aujourd'hui on fait vraiment partie
d'une classe de travailleurs pauvres
moi je dis que tout le monde devrait
pouvoir vivre de son salaire
un débat axé sur les solutions et chacun
y va à ces suggestions
en france les entreprises font des
bénéfices massivement et personnes entre
la couleur le les ouvriers les
entreprises n'en voit pas la couleur
c'est toujours pour augmenter les marges
des actionnaires qui sont le bout du
monde et qui ne cesse d'en vouloir plus
et encore plus y encore plus lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale
taxer davantage les entreprises et bien
nantis augmenter le salaire minimum
autant d'options longuement débattu il
ya deux façons d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat soit on augmente les salaires
soit on diminue les prélèvements
augmenter les salaires quand on va dire
ça des artisans qui je pense que demain
ils auront plus de boulot il y avait
besoin de ce débat 1 il ya le radeau
dans d'autres lieux
après plus de deux heures des
discussions l'assemblée citoyenne tire
ses conclusions et transmettra au
gouvernement
ces recommandations un acte de foi pour
patrick
si ces attentes restent modérées pour la
suite il est surtout satisfait d'avoir
pu y participer
ça a lancé le débat ce qui est des
chèques
une grande première en france j'ai 60
ans chez jamais vu de débat en france
une chose est certaine le grand débat
national semble susciter l'adhésion des
français
plus de 2000 assemblées citoyennes sont
programmés pour les prochains mois et
plus d'un demi million de contributions
directes ont déjà été remises au
gouvernement
le grand défi par la suite sera d'en
faire la synthèse d'en tirer les
conclusions
et bien sûr de les mettre en pratique
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
clermont ferrand